[Music]
in terms of seeing famous people that we
love died from drugs should make us
question why we so stigmatized and
attack people with addictions I mean
some of our most beloved artists
musicians writers have been addicted I
mean I find it kind of interesting that
we don't see addiction as a white
problem when you have like William
Burroughs and Lou Reed and Kurt Cobain
he and I could list 20 other you know
heroin addicted rock stars so you know
this is a condition that can affect not
just anybody but people who are in some
sort of emotional pain it addiction
kicks people who are already down and it
doesn't look like celebrities should be
that kind of person
but I think that a lot of the drive and
the grit and the you know what you need
to in order to achieve great success is
also a risk for addiction because in
order to be a successful rock star you
have to persist despite rejection a lot
um and you need to be able to just keep
going and keep going and if you if that
kind of drive and passion gets focused
on a drug it is particularly destructive
so I think in order to help you know
deal with opioid addiction for one we
need to have naloxone in every first-aid
kit there is absolutely no reason why
people who are with why people who are
surrounded by other people should ever
die of an overdose if you are injecting
and other people are there which is the
case 50 to 60 percent of the time
naloxone should be there and this is not
going to encourage more drug use because
it's an awful experience to get awakened
within the lock zone but it will save
lives and so that's one thing one way we
can turn the tide on this the other way
that I think we can turn the tide on
the addiction is we really need to
provide greater access to drugs like
methadone and suboxone which is also
called buprenorphine in order those two
drugs taken indefinitely ie
potentially for life are the only things
that cut the death rate by 50% and if we
really want to solve this problem we
could get rid of half of it if we could
enroll many more people in these
maintenance programs now there's a lot
of barriers to that one is that we only
allow doctors prescribing buprenorphine
to see a hundred patients now they've
just raised it to 200 this is ridiculous
they can prescribe opioids for pain to
ten thousand patients but you can only
prescribe for addiction to one hundred
patients this is really silly we also
have this idea that you can't provide
these medications without also providing
counseling and you know we don't do that
for any other medical service we don't
say oh you can only get your insulin if
you do you know X counseling on diet or
whatever we realize that people need the
tools to stay alive regardless of if
they're improving as quickly as we would
like them to do and forced counseling
doesn't actually help anyway so what we
should do is we should have different
thresholds for treatments so with
buprenorphine some people may just want
to show up and get a dose and that's it
and that will work as sheer harm
reduction that should be available in
emergency rooms you need to register
people so that you don't end up people
getting multiple doses and you need to
be a little more careful with methadone
than with buprenorphine because there is
a big overdose risk for patients who are
naive to methadone and it's a difficult
drug to prescribe so that needs to be a
little more controlled but we have it
way too controlled
and we isolate it from the rest of
Medicine in a way that we don't do with
any other drug so on you know we have
the tools to dramatically reduce the
death toll for celebrities and for
everybody else we're just not using them
[Music]